de québec à edmonton de charlottetown à
yellowknife
ils ont tous pour mandat de représenter
leurs électeurs mais les conditions dans
lesquelles les députés du parlement
provinciaux effectuent leur travail
varie considérablement
à l'heure actuelle le salaire d'un
député provincial varie de 60 8500 $ à
l'île du prince édouard à 127 1200 en
alberta au québec c'est 90 mille huit
cent en ontario 116500 les députés
québécois ont cependant droit à une
allocation de dépenses non imposable de
16 mille 400 dollars ce à quoi n'ont pas
droit la plupart de leurs collègues des
autres provinces
n'empêche qu'en faisant passer leur
salaire global 140 mille 100 dollars les
députés québécois deviendraient les
mieux payés du canada chez les volontés
de rapports indépendants qui a été
demandée pour que le touring-club profit
d'intérêts mais le salaire ne fait pas
foi tout cas la lourdeur de la tâche
varient passablement d'un parlement à
l'autre les députés québécois siège en
moyenne 83 jours par année
c'est une fois et demie plus qu'en
alberta deux fois plus qu'à l'île du
prince édouard on parle d'un travail et
exigeante un aphte travail important que
la tâche de député c'est aussi alourdi
le nombre d'heures de travail passer en
commission parlementaire a augmenté
considérablement depuis cinq ans c'est
plus de 1500 heures en moyenne chaque
année au québec selon des estimations
c'est environ quatre fois plus qu'en
ontario dur ce sont les champions
parmi l'ensemble des assemblées
législatives qu'ont pu la chambre des
communes pour siéger en commission
il n'y a pas une assemblée aucun ado qui
ajoute à ces différences salariales
s'ajoute aussi des différences dans les
autres conditions de travail comme le
régime de retraite ou les assurances
collectives des conditions qui
s'amoindrir ont et qui permettront de
générer des économies
si le projet de loi déposé aujourd'hui
est adoptée ici hugo lavallée radio
canada québec